the IMF is warning Lebanon urgently
needs reforms to prevent hyper inflation
a conditional agreement was reached last
year on a three billion dollar bone but
loan to save its economy but needed
changes have not been made now
protesters tried to storm government
headquarters in Beirut on Wednesday
police find tear gas to break up the
crowds many of those are retired
soldiers demanding a living pension
well I mean Salam is lebanon's Minister
of economy and trade he's in Beirut for
us good to have you with us the IMF is
saying that Lebanon is at a very
dangerous moment would you agree
yes absolutely
Lebanon is at a very very critical
transition period and our staff level
agreement with the IMF as well is
witnessing a a very critical uh point
now of discussions uh we had the the
team visiting from the IMF this entire
week with all the stakeholders and IMF
negotiations team
and the Lebanese government which are
which I am a member of
and they shared with us their very very
serious and legitimate concerns
regarding the speed uh to move towards
reforms versus the speed of the uh uh
incline and the economy and the speed of
you know the collapse in our monetary
system as well so how is it how has it
got to this point I mean it was over a
year ago that Lebanon and the IMF agreed
to the reforms why have they not been
implemented
um it's a very very very simple uh uh
you know answer to that it's the
political will the political will in
Lebanon unfortunately has been
stagnating every every uh a potential
beam of Hope or action that we tried
really uh even though we are part of
this political system as a government
but it's way the decision-making in
Lebanon has not only revolve around the
government unfortunately we have the
parliament we have all the political
parties we have the influence of the
regional situation as well that really
decides a lot of what is happening or
what is going to happen in Lebanon and
despite the fact that our government has
produced and delivered most if not all
of the uh uh uh the draft close to the
parliament we are still due to the lack
of political will or a decision to let
Lebanon really begin making a
breakthrough with the IMF and making a
breakthrough towards the recovery we're
still discussing uh and negotiating
within the parliament uh laws that need
to be out immediately and they are more
than exhausted they have been with this
they exhausted the discussions of those
laws so what are the particular reforms
that need to be made and and that people
are blocking why are they blocking these
ones
yeah well you know I mean uh we have
witnessed that you know what Lebanon is
going through Now is really a transition
period from an old system to a new
system we are working towards an a a
complete change we want to start with a
clean slate because we know that the old
system the old way of doing things
within the Lebanese government whether
if it's a monetary fiscal or economic uh
policy it has proven failure and we are
trying to really start on A New Path
with a new framework with the IMF that's
why we are emphasizing the importance of
the IMF because it's putting a new
framework that over three decades none
of the Lebanese governments passed
Lebanese governments have managed to put
together to build a true economy to
build through financial system to build
a resilience economy with a vision this
is what we're trying to do the fight
between the old system and the new
system is really that's the stall made
point that we are all now fighting over
so you're basically are about yes you're
basically trying to overhaul a system
that's been in place for at least 30
years are you optimistic that you're
actually going to be able to do that
they call me one of the optimistic
ministers and I have to be optimistic
because we have to take Lebanon uh to
another place we have to take Lebanon
out of this miserable situation that we
are going through now especially the the
social conditions and the economic
conditions and given that it has been
proven over and over again that the old
system the old way the old methodology
that has been followed by the previous
governments has proven complete failure
we need to go to a new place that's why
it's important to follow the IMF
framework it's important to have a
political will to take the country out
of this situation and to begin really
going on a path of Reform and Recovery
today rather than tomorrow I mean time
is our worst enemy now every day of
delay is a is taking the country into a
more difficult place and making the
livelihood of people more dangerous
that's what I wanted to touch on because
the IMF has said that everybody will
need to take losses but so far it's only
really been the depositors at banks that
have really suffered and lost their
savings is there any form of recovery
plan in place to help the people of
Lebanon
yes I mean for for for for myself and
for deliverance governments the
depositor's rights is really a sacred
right and I have said that many many
times before we cannot allow any
agreement we cannot allow any deal we
cannot allow any structure to jeopardize
the rights of depositors they are
depositors that have put their money
within the trust that the government the
Central Bank along with the private
sector banks will preserve and protect
their deposits by no means at all I
accept or any government should accept
that the monies of the depositors will
be the most jeopardized or will or they
will be the ones to pay the fees or to
pay the losses this is the
responsibility of the government this is
the responsibility of the private sector
banks that have a a five-year duty to
protect the monies of the people
invested in those Banks and put in those
Banks and we are trying now along
with the private sector the central bank
and Lebanese government to find the best
scenario to come out with an agreement
that protects those depositors monies
any agreement that goes in any other
direction will be unfair will be in my
own opinion a disaster on the economy
and on The credibility of this or any
following government
minister of economy and trade for
Lebanon thank you very much for taking
the time to speak to us